well first of all um topanga you don't
age
thanks that means yeah i mean i do i
really do but thank you what are you
doing tell us all well there's a little
bit of botox and um a lot of sleep and
you know argan oil
i love that for you
thank you
well it's so nice to meet you guys i
know you all have a new podcast coming
out what can you tell us and what's it
like reuniting and like
being together right now well being
together is not that unusual we're
actually together a lot yeah we hang out
all the time so that's not unusual but
yeah we've been uh we've been starting
to get together to do a podcast where
we're gonna watch our show which is
unusual uh because i've never seen it uh
yeah yeah there's like maybe a handful
of episodes i've seen over the years so
this is going to be interesting uh these
guys did watch it back in the day but
haven't seen it since as far as i know
wow so yeah so we started getting
together we're going to record our
conversations about watching boyd meets
world oh my god like you still love that
show like so this is exciting did you
want to know what ryder and i are doing
to stay as young looking as we are
because well here's the thing we didn't
get asked yeah i was like danielle you
look like yeah you look so young and wet
i grew up literally obsessing over her
as a little girl and she looks the same
so i'm confused it's been years a little
bit of botox a lot of sleep
and what was the last of some kind of
oil
and jason in the argonauts oh yeah so
very excited i love that is there
anybody that you're going to see tonight
that you are going to totally like fan
over is there anyone you're a super fan
of i am a
super fan of shawn mendes but like who
isn't but i also like have already met
john mendez so i'm going to try to make
i'm going to try to like keep the
composure together but i'm a i'm like
i'm a stan if you will oh
yeah
do you guys have anyone no no i'm so old
yeah so old which you already commented
on but yeah apparently i also have
someone else oh lotto oh
i am so excited did you know about lotto
girl i am so excited by the way i think
in i'm gonna predict it right now in two
to three years she's gonna be headlining
this event yes okay we got a prediction
we got a prediction bring this back up
in two to three years she will be
headlining yes do you guys have any
performers that you're excited to see
no is pink floyd planned
i'm kidding i'm very excited to see
everybody we're at wango tango exactly i
know who we're introducing we're
introducing charlie pooh which is cool
yeah that that's pretty cool yeah okay
we're excited for that i see excitement
in your eyes i'm excited for that i'm
excited for that
we did this is good again it's the botox
there's nothing in the eyes
the sleep and the argonauts
who are you guys listening to right now
summer playlist vibes
i mean i was gonna say
i have an early advance of like some of
sabrina carpenter's music so i have been
i've been like i'm like that's really
what i've been listening to um
yeah what else what are you guys
listening to
the remastering of pink floyd again
any music after say 1981 i don't really
know what it is so i know some of the
mid-80s stuff but after that i'm kind of
lost so yeah awesome it was so nice
talking to you guys that was so fun and
you guys do look great okay you do
it's just like
i just you do you guys look good
everyone looks good okay seriously it's
just it was a moza childhood moment i
was having a moment okay
i i listen
benjamin button
it's me it's her thank you guys yes
rocket